- Hey folks, Dr. Mike here,
I'm about to play the game,
Idle Human, which I got this
funny shirt someone sent me,
that's perfect for a day like today
where we're just gonna sit back,
have fun, and play a medical game.
(whoops)
(jazz music)
Tap here to start human creation.
Tap, tap, tap, to create cells.
Cells are required to form the human.
And it looks like the faster I tap it.
(rapid clicking)
Alright, so we just built up the tarsals,
the metatarsals, now we're
building up the tib fib,
the tibia and the fibula,
which are the shin bones.
Oh, the skull is made up
of 29 different bones.
The more you know.
A single human brain generates
more electrical impulses
in a day than all the
telephones in the world, wow.
There's so many fun facts here.
We should call this Fun Fact Game.
50,000 cells in your body
died and were replaced
by new ones while you were
reading this sentence.
Now we're building the thigh bone,
which is called the femur.
It's actually one of the
strongest bones in the human body,
but we gotta build it up.
Right-handed people live on average
nine years longer than left-handed people.
I know a large part of that has
something to do with workplace accidents,
because most tools are designed
for right-handed people.
I actually said that in
my medical memes episode.
About two-thirds of people tilt their head
to the right when kissing.
(smacks lips)
When you blush, your
stomach also turns red.
Aww, that's so cute, I don't
know if that's true though.
Actually, it might be
true because there's a lot
of histamine release that
occurs in your stomach.
Human beings are the only living things
which sleep on their backs.
Come on, there's no way that's true.
Ooh, unlock the pelvis bones!
(upbeat music)
Now I'm building up the hands,
which contain the
metacarpals and the carpals.
Then we're gonna start
building up the forearm,
which contains the radius
and the ulna bones.
Why is the pelvis so expensive?
(upbeat music)
(whoops)
I just got double the speed.
This sound might be getting annoying,
but I'm growing the human body.
Come on, build that body, build
that body, build that body.
The total weight of the
bacteria in the human body
is two kilos, ugh, that's
almost five pounds of bacteria.
- Doody!
- My hand is fatiguing
but I want to get it.
One million cells.
Let's grow those hands.
(whoops)
I'm already onto that humerus, baby.
There are more than a
hundred different viruses
which cause a cold.
This actually a great talking point,
because when patients come in they're like
which virus do I have?
I'm like doesn't matter,
they're like please test me.
And will you pay for it,
'cause your insurance won't.
They're like no.
Oh my god, if I don't at
least finish a leg right now,
I'm gonna be upset.
(whoops)
The legs are complete.
Let's do the stomach.
Oh look at that, the stomach
is building rather quickly.
Oh I unlocked a liver.
My finger's getting so
tired, you have no idea.
I think this is something
that I have to like sit
for days and hours.
(cap clicking)
(exhales)
I love matcha.
It makes me feel loved.
♪ Matcha, smack, all right ♪
what?
I get 3200 now, oh my god,
I'm gonna win this game
so easy right now.
- [Digital Voice] Later.
- Oh we finished the hands.
♪ Legs and hands are done ♪
It says my human is 7% completed.
I will not stop this game
until I complete this human.
The secret is to like vibrate your hand.
- [Woman] So that's hot.
(rapid clicking)
- Kidneys unlocked and
my bicep's getting tired.
Look at that, I got the ribcage.
See, they try to hold
me down but I'm ready.
- I'm ready, I'm ready.
- There you go, heart is unlocked now.
Look at my human coming together.
Brain is unlocked, yay!
I gotta do 1.2 trillion
to get the brain upgraded
that's too much.
The cerebral cortex is popping off,
the medulla oblongata.
That ribcage looks real.
Alright, one more.
(sighs)
1.7 billion to unlock the spine.
There you go, his spinal
cord is unlocked, yay!
Let's upgrade the spinal cord.
3.6 trillion cells, that ridiculous.
It's trying to hold us back,
but I'm not gonna lettuce.
You're on my team, I love you, yeah.
Now in order to build the next organ,
which is the skull, we need
the nerves at a thousand.
(rapid clicking)
It's so slow.
- [Digital Voice] Later.
- Oh I need, 1.2 trillion, trillion.
See I've been investing
in this tapping thing,
maybe the tapping thing
wasn't the way to go.
The human is 25% ready.
Look at that, the mouth is unlocked.
I'm telling you our body's
at 40%, we're on fire now.
- [Digital Voice] One eternity later.
- Ears are unlocked.
My iPhone's probably
like your screen time is
through the roof.
What are you doing Dr. Mike?
By the way, I don't
recommend this to anybody.
(sighs)
Yeah, we unlocked blood.
Leg muscles unlocked.
This person's starting
to look like a human.
Half of my human is done.
I don't think anyone's ever finished
this game in one session.
All my organs are complete.
All my bones are complete.
The only thing that's left
is like little organs.
This is very doable.
We got the head muscles are all done.
Oh my god, look how the body looks,
I haven't even looked at it.
The pecs are coming in.
Woo!
Let's build these leg muscles.
Squats for days baby.
All the muscles are complete.
All the bones are complete.
All the organs are complete.
The brain is now complete.
The spinal cord, the nose
is about to be complete.
The mouth is complete.
The ears are complete.
I'm building up the skin.
Look at the skin.
(gasps)
10 trillion for a piece of skin.
That's ridiculous!
- It's too damn high.
- He's looks, too
muscular and puffy though.
Finish that skin.
Hair is unlocked.
I think I'm done.
(inhales)
Congratulations, male completed!
- It's alive, it's alive!
- I need to synthesize his jeans now.
(chuckles)
His clothing!
This crazy, that they threw in clothing.
Your cells don't make clothing folks.
I'm doing this strictly
for you to watch me suffer.
This is crazy.
I'll never be able to finish this.
I completed his jeans.
I like his shirt.
His hoodie!
I gotta do his hoodie now.
This is absolutely ridiculous.
I quit this game.
Should I do it?
No, I can't do it.
I just spent $21 on this game.
This is a lesson to everyone at home,
'cause the whole purpose is
not to get you to spend money.
I thought this would be a
good learning opportunity,
instead all I learned is that
I'm a susceptible sucker.
Oh my god, I spent too
many hours doing that.
I put together a playlist for you
of my favorite games.
Watch those, there's
something to learn there,
we can have fun, you don't
have to watch me suffer.
Be happy and healthy if you watch that
and I'll see you over there.
(jazz music)